this is all rest a world covered in a
sea of clouds
many giant life-forms called Titans live
in this cloud sea and the people have
built their countries and lives on top
of these creatures in the middle of this
world stands the World Tree and it's
said that at the top of it lies Elysium
and Adeleke land of plenty many great
powers rule over regions of all res the
kingdom of Araya is one of them its
territory contained within their title
the Orion's deeply respect nature
posting advanced biotechnology for now
we should keep our troops mobilized
while we monitor the situation
their rival the militaristic Empire of
more our Dane is another controlling
Titans through mechanical means they
bring heavy armaments to bear as their
necks other lands in a bid to save their
own from ruin and debris sure I doubt he
would have been stopped even by an army
5,000 stronger the Imperial province of
Gama the plentiful land now fallen under
our Danian control and the in Deline
praetorium whose people revere and
worship the titans
window controls the supply of core
crystals which blades are born off and
so despite being a theocracy they hold
much influence over the world's military
affairs
next the Argentum trade guild a shrewd
consortium the traders they do well for
themselves by deftly navigating the
strained relations between other nations
and exploiting wartime demas
and last but not least torna carrying
out secret operations under the cloud
sea to achieve their mysterious goals
before allah this world will fall into
turmoil over efforts to find the
legendary blade the aegis that is
precisely the kind of scenario that I
mean to prevent a just must be destroyed
I'm guessing your goal is Elysium dream
who will find the aegis who will make it
to Elysium only time will tell
welcome to all West the world of
Xenoblade Chronicles to nileen Lisa soda
oh yes that's me right there I may be
relatively small but I am also a Titan
and this little troublemaker is the
protagonist of our story Rick's who
lives on my back I suppose you could say
I'm his landlord and his guardian too he
refers to me as Gramps
you'll make only the same preps used to
work as a Selfridge
scavenging useful resources from beneath
the cloud sea until one day he met a
girl named Hiram and the two set off on
a quest to deliver her safely to Elysium
can you believe he accepted such a lofty
job just to impress the girl oh yes and
this is also me that'll be adorable if I
do say so myself
[Music]
these elaborate chronicles - you too
will embark on a journey across the
Titans back see each Titan fosters a
unique scenery very different from its
neighbors some have big open fields
while others post huge caverns set deep
within the Titans own body
remember we Titans are living beings
each with our own quirks which you must
learn to navigate because you also cross
paths with many a dangerous creature on
these Titans
it's their home - but it's sadly
inevitable that we've got heads from
time to time those who fight together
with synthetic life-forms called blades
like Rex tars unknown as trifles when
drivers do battle their weapons and
powers are granted to them by blades
such as Pyrrha for example after three
drivers and three blades can work
together at any one time
as you continue attacking with your
normal weapons you constantly work
toward charging up your driver artists
these special abilities run mechanical
with some allowing you to inflict extra
damage depending on your position while
other
arcane arts can cause HP oceans to
appear just tears the my sleep and works
closely retired a battle to know when
best to deploy on blades verses of
warfare trusty drivers by using blade
arts to increase the power of their
attacks their accuracy at the light
[Music]
that way the drivers can focus on
playing a more active role in the
battery just wait till you encounter
some tougher opposition things won't
always go your way so it's important to
learn the benefits of switching blades
by using icons called coal crystals
drivers can awaken new pregnancy this is
known as resonance you aren't limited to
just one a single driver can bond with
multiple blades the weapons and arts
available to you depend on the blades
with which you borrow and you never know
what kind of date you'll get until you
awaken
sometimes you will muster up some very
special night looks like you hit the
jackpot this time
you can pick up the three blades in the
bathroom with you with each braid wave
either an attack attack event a typed or
a healer type which important to switch
grades and tactics in step with your
situation
[Music]
like I always say there's no better game
plan than using the right blade for the
job at hand as a basic rule of thumb for
drivers
you should always stay abreast of the
blades your party members in QC and
strategize accordingly by using your
arts you'll fill up your blades special
advantage when you finally activate one
of the specials the driver will return
the weapon to its blade owner enabling
the blade to deliver a devastating
attack blade specials have four levels
of intensity and I must take level three
and four are a bit too wild for my taste
so what do you you are still a bit weak
but one day you may work your way up to
being a great driver yourself there is
much more to learn but consider this a
seat even combine the hearts into
something wrong and really turn the time
it's fast by big time your journey
through the clouds begins when Xenoblade
Chronicles 2 launches on Nintendo switch
December the 1st the world of all rest
is waiting for you alongside the regular
version we will be offering a special
edition including a sound selection CD a
special medal game case and 220 page
hardbound art book you can also look
forward to the release of a Xenoblade
Chronicles 2 themed Nintendo switch pro
controller sold separately